Speaker 1: Failed. Former President Donald
Trump indicted 34 counts, reportedly. Donald
Trump expected to be in New York City in court on
Tuesday to be booked, mug shot and fingerprinted,
arraigned and subsequently released.
Donald Trump has absolutely lost his mind,
posting the entire night to truth social. We will
look at that. Many of you agree with me that Trump
will not see the inside of a prison cell for even
one day. But that being said, this shows that no
one is above the law. So many people saying this
is unprecedented and this is not justice. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no. If Trump was above the
law, that would not be justice and he will
get his day in court. He is innocent until proven
guilty. And I believe that this first indictment
out of New York City may be the first of many,
with prosecutors waiting to see will someone
be the first to indict a former president? The
Associated Press reports Donald Trump indicted,
expected to surrender early next week. The exact
nature of the charges is unclear as of Friday
because the indictment remains under seal, But
they stem from payments made during the 2016
campaign to silence the claims of an extramarital
sexual encounter, of course, with Stormy Daniels.
Trump has assailed the entire thing, says it's
all bogus and nonsense. This is historic in every
single way. Donald Trump Wildly Posting to Truth
Social. All night I'm scrolling it for people to
see. Multiple times per hour, 3 hours ago and then
going to eventually a lot of posts 3 hours ago.
Then eventually getting to 7 hours ago which would
have put it at 330 in the morning and 9 hours ago,
130 just posting, posting. I'm going to
stop scrolling because people are going to
get dizzy. Donald Trump initially reacting to the
indictment with a misspelled post in which he says
he has been vindicated. Not only is this the first
time that a former president has been vindicated
by a grand jury. This is the first time a grand
jury has indicated any president. And of course,
it is beyond parody that even this Trump can't
string together a reasonable statement about
Trump posting to troth quote. And by the way,
there's capital letters all over this thing.
I'm not even going to mention. Each time
Trump randomly capitalizes, these thugs and
radical left monsters have just indicated the 45th
president of the United States of America and the
leading Republican candidate by far for the 2024
nomination for president. Here he engages, caps,
lock and says this is an attack on our country,
the likes of which has never been seen before.
Remember, Trump was a one man crime spree as
president, the likes of which the country has
never seen before. Trump continuing in all capital
letters. It is likewise a continuing attack on
our once free and fair elections. No, it's not.
The USA is now a third world nation. A nation in
serious decline. So sad. Then Trump putting out a
more formal statement which was no less unhinged.
I won't read the entire thing. I'm not going to
subject you to that. But in the first paragraph,
of course, he calls the prosecution a political
persecution as well as election interference. He
includes the term witch hunt and many other
things. In the second paragraph, he says,
wrongly, that Democrats cheated and have stolen.
Of course, it was Trump who tried to steal the
2020 election. In the third paragraph, he
says, This has never been done in nation's
history. That's true. But remember, there has
never been a one man crime spree like Trump in
the Oval Office in American history. There has
never been a president who surrounded himself
with so many reliably crooked people. Then
he attacks Alvin Bragg, linking him to
George Soros. And lastly, he says this will
backfire on Joe Biden. Of course, Joe Biden
has nothing to do with it. Tuesday, booking an
arraignment expected. You know, on Tuesday, big,
strong guy with tears in his eyes might go up to
Trump and say, Sir, I'll be taking your mug shot
now. Please don't do anything stupid. This shows
no one is above the law. That is justice. Although
Trump will not serve a day of prison time,
the hope is that this is only the beginning.